deals we can get today bianca
hey good morning sheri you know lots of
people they got their credit card ready
they're ready to burn a hole in it
with all the deals that they're going to
take advantage of from the comfort of
their home of course and their couch or
even their bed right
and the retail association of nevada
says that there's going to be about 75
percent of folks that are going to all
take advantage of online shopping today
and that is an increase from last year
actually a 10 percent increase compared
to last year
while people search websites local
businesses are also preparing to offer
holiday deals
for the first time sunrise coffee and
mothership coffee roasters
plan to participate in cyber monday the
owner says the pandemic forced her to
start selling products online
she plans to offer discount coffee bags
and gift boxes for cyber monday
cyber monday is always something i
thought like that wasn't like part of
our program
but obviously like this whole year has
brought like a lot of new learning for
me using like digital tools and online
resources
even some casinos and resorts are taking
advantage of increased eyeballs on the
web today as a way to fill up rooms
after taking a hit during this pandemic
station casinos has got some deals for
you also
red rock casino and green valley ranch
resort have
staycation packages and luxury suites
available
and because of the high unemployment as
we're all familiar with
the retail association of nevada says
the word of this season
is uncertainty and of course that's why
there's going to be so many deals today
to at least
get some sales in reporting live bianca
holman eight news now
there'll be a lot of clicking pointing
and clicking going on i think online
today